ce 9 juin marque donc un nouveau cap
dans le déconfinement couvre-feu
repoussé à 23 heures réouverture des
clubs de sport vous en parlait hier et
mais aussi des salles de restaurant pour
l'instant avec une jauge à 50% mais
c'est déjà un grand pas
le reportage à tour et amboise d'audrey
champigny et allen chapelet 12h20 ce
mercredi 9 juin après sept mois de
fermeture cet établissement bistronomie
tourangeau rouvre ses portes à
l'intérieur les premiers clients sont
déjà à table et christophe le chef de
salle retrouve ses marques au chômage
partiel depuis le mois de novembre comme
les cinq autres salariés du restaurant
il doit se remettre en mémoire quelques
détails
le code de la larme pour pour entrer
dans le restaurant en face c'est quelque
chose qui était il était passé au dessus
de la tête et
et après c'est c'est des petits des
petites choses comme ça qui reviennent
au fur et à mesure et ça va se passer de
mieux en mieux voilà il y avait besoin
besoin besoin de de retravailler dans
les cuisines
aussi il faut retrouver le rythme pour
ce premier midi de réouverture une
vingtaine de couverts sont prévues la
qualité doit être au rendez vous c'est
l'une des priorités du chef et pour lui
aussi ce retour derrière les fourneaux
et finalement assez stressant c'est
compliqué de reprendre
et puis ça attaque fort très très fort
dès soir on est presque complet donc
donc c'est c'est beaucoup de beaucoup
d'émotion de plein de choses en même
temps en fin de compte et du coup on est
un petit peu nous même perturbé par tout
ça changement de décor direction amboise
dans ce restaurant troglos en 19 ans de
métier parce qu'elle n'avait jamais
étant son four à fouet ce midi seule une
petite vingtaine de personnes habituées
locaux d'habitude à cette période de
l'année il reçoit beaucoup d'étrangers
environ 65 % de sa clientèle
beaucoup de japonais beaucoup coréens
américains des gens du monde entier et
ils feront pas là malheureusement
pendant un petit bout de temps alors on
espère que nos amis européens viendront
nous dire bonjour on a quelques quelques
italiens espagnols en a des touches mais
pas pour tout de suite
et aujourd'hui luis ce petit nombre pour
nous oui c'est une renaissance
les clients vont désormais pouvoir
prendre le temps de guinée à l'intérieur
comme à l'extérieur
le couvre-feu passe ce soir à 23h